the superhero craze is showing no sign
of slowing down anytime
soon and it seems like the next few
years are filled to the brim with comic
book and superhero movies
but what's actually coming out and when
here's
everything you need to know about these
upcoming superhero movies
sylvester stallone appeared to retire
his iconic john ramble character with
2019's ramble last blood
but the actor clearly isn't planning on
retiring himself anytime soon
he'll go from action hero to superhero
in
2021 samaritan a film about a child who
discovers the secret behind a long
forgotten hero's disappearance
samaritan is directed by julius avery
who earned praise for helming the world
war ii zombie thriller overlord in 2018.
when he was offered the chance to work
with stallone on his next feature
he jumped at it avery told deadline sly
is a hero of mine
i'm incredibly thrilled to be working
with such an iconic actor
on this very special project with balboa
productions and mgm
avery reportedly struck up a great
relationship with salon on set
who called him a wonderful director when
the movie wrapped in november 2020
after a number of unfortunate
coronavirus related delays
stallone shared in an instagram post
entire crew was tested down to the last
person
every day for covit which amounted to
thousands upon thousands of tests
and we came through like champs
samaritan is now due for release on june
4th 2021
after years of teasing marvel finally
announced that a standalone black widow
movie was coming at comic con 2019
by the end of the year we had our first
teaser for the film
a prequel that takes place after the
events of captain america civil war
the movie follows natasha romanov as she
goes under the radar and returns to
russia
where she reunites with her old friends
and family these new characters include
florence pugh as elena bulova rachel
weiss as molina vostakov
and david harbour as alexi shastikov aka
the red guardian
the movie also features a sinister new
villain in taskmaster
as well as the return of william hertz
daddius ross
blackwidow has been subject to a whole
heap of controversy in speculation
due to its numerous delays as well as
disney's apparent reluctance to release
it on disney plus
now though the movie's status has
finally been confirmed
black widow will hit theaters and disney
plus premiere
access simultaneously on july 9 2021
one of the highlights of 2020's dc
fandom
was the roll call for james guns the
suicide squad which officially
introduced the ensemble cast of the soft
reboot
a number of actors including margot
robbie and viola davis reprised their
role from
2016 suicide squad and will be joined by
a host of new recruits to boot
gunn is clearly pretty excited about his
anti-hero team-up flick
promising that it'll be different to
anything else he's ever made
the featurette also revealed that plenty
of big action set pieces are in store
with producer peter safran describing
the suicide squad as
kind of like a classic war movie this is
a gritty 1970s war movie
combined with brilliance of james gunn's
characters and comedy
a handful of other trailers were
released in early 2021
and they only seem to further prove what
the original featurette suggested that
this is going to be
one crazy movie the suicide squad will
be released in theaters
and on hbo max on august 6 2021
above all else marvel's self-professed
goal for xiang chi and the legend of the
ten rings
is to offer their own perspective on
asian identity
the studio has hired asian and asian
american filmmakers to make sure that
happens
and judging by the character's history
that's a pretty smart move
the hands of shang chi master of kung fu
comics began as an unofficial
continuation of bruce lee's legacy
and while marvel's intentions may have
been noble
the execution wasn't always perfect
making controversial pulp villain
fumanchu
chongqi's father was undoubtedly a bad
move for example and one that's quite
rightly been retconned
the job of bringing chongqi into the
modern age belongs to chinese-american
screenwriter dave callahan
and japanese hawaiian director destin
daniel creighton
the titular role meanwhile has gone to
chinese canadian actor simu liu
at comic con 2019 liu revealed i was
cast on tuesday
i screen tested on sunday in new york
this is the craziest craziest dream
the actor who was perhaps best known for
the comedy series fresh off the boat
told the packed hall h that his parents
moved to north america with next to
nothing
he said all i've ever wanted was to make
them proud
shang chi also features tony li young as
the villainous mandarin and aquafina as
shang chi's best friend katie
the movie hits theaters on september 3rd
2021
in june 2019 amy pascal confirmed that
venom star tom hardy would be reprising
the role of eddie brock
in an interview with fandango the
producer said tom hardy will be back
magnificently playing that character as
no one else can
pascal made no mention of venom director
ruben fleischer however
as it turned out flasher would not be
returning instead
hardy later confirmed that actor and
director andy serkis would be taking the
reins for the venom sequel
circus made his directorial debut in
2017 with heartwarming drama breathe
improved his blockbuster chops the
following year with mowgli
legend of the jungle venom's mid-credits
scenes made it pretty clear that sony
was plotting a sequel
it follows brock as he visits woody
harrison's cletus cassidy in prison
when i get out of here and i will
there's going to be carnage just what
form will that carnage take
you can probably guess but if you want
to know for sure
you'll need to see venom let there be
carnage the movie arrives in theaters on
september 24
2021 due to the coronavirus pandemic
marvel's eternals has been bumped to the
end of 2021
luckily fans have already been given a
few hints and teasers about the
barrier-breaking cosmic blockbuster
the film will apparently take place over
a period of 7 000 years
according to kevin feige and will follow
the exploits of the eponymous immortals
known as the eternals
the impressive ensemble cast includes
angelina jolie as thina
richard madden as icarus and kid
harrington as the black knight dane
whitman
meanwhile jimmy chan will appear as the
human-loving cersei
kumail nanjiani is playing kingo lauren
ridloff is makari
bryan tyree henry is fastos leah mchugh
is sprite
don lee is gilgamesh barry kuhn is druik
and telma hayek is ajac leader of the
group
sounds like a lot that's comic books for
you mcu overlord kevin feige has also
confirmed that eternals will feature the
mcu's first openly gay characters
actor has slayman later told
entertainment weekly
i'm married to the gay superhero fastos
played by atlanta's brian tyree henry
and we represent a gay family and have a
child marvel's first deaf superhero
makari will also debut
making this the most representative mcu
movie to date
according to a leaked tie-in toy the
villain of the picture will be crow
a powerful member of the hideous species
known as the deviants
nomad land director and oscar
front-runner chloe zao
directs from a script by matthew and
ryan furpo
eternals will be released on november
5th 2021
over the last few months news on the
upcoming spider-man has continued to
trickle through
some of the most tantalizing tidbits
about the movie titled spider-man no way
home
include the fact that jamie foxx and
alfred molina are both returning to
marvel as electro and dr
octopus respectively in october 2020
the hollywood reporter's sources
revealed that fox's character from the
andrew garfield movies was set for a
shock return
in october 2020 and a few months later
they revealed that molina who went
toe-to-toe with toby maguire's body is
also going to feature in the movie
where do all these guys come from fox
himself later hinted at garfield and
maguire reprising their roles in a
hastily deleted instagram post
and there's been talk of emma stone and
kirsten dunst coming back too
three generations of spider-man movies
could allegedly collide in this highly
anticipated three-quarter
but how is this actually possible well
sony has been embracing the idea of a
shared multiverse with its animated
spiderverse franchise and we know the
concept will play a big part in upcoming
mcu projects
most notably culminating with doctor
strange in the multiverse of madness
fittingly benedict cumberbatch's steven
strange will reportedly play a
supporting role in holland's third solo
film
taking over as peter parker's mentor the
movie swings into theaters on december
17
2021 sony dropped the first trailer for
morbius in january 2020
and it was met with a mixture of
confusion and excitement
the three-minute clip was essentially a
mini origin story for lesser-known
marvel anti-hero dr michael morbius
a brilliant scientist who turns to
vampirism
after his attempt to cure his rare blood
disease have mixed results
morbius debuted as an enemy of peter
parker in 1971's
amazing spider-man number 101 but became
more of a sympathetic figure in later
issues
while this movie is very much part of
sony's own universe of marvel characters
the morbius teaser contained a few
easter eggs that raised questions about
the film's relationship to the mcu
for example the word murderer has been
graffitied across an image of spidey in
one scene
indicating that this is tom holland's
version of the character
who was framed by mysterio in spider-man
far from home
if that wasn't enough michael keaton
shows up as
adrian toombs confirming that morbius is
tied to the
mcu in some way or another as such some
fans are predicting that morbius might
sow the seeds for a big screen
sinister six but just what form that
movie might take in sony's universe
has yet to be seen morbius will be
released on january 21st
2022 the first trailer for robert
pattinson's upcoming batman movie
dropped during dc
fandom revealing plot details first
looks at villains
and the darkest big screen version of
the cape crusader yet
patterson's stripped down batsuit is on
full display in the trailer
including a particularly shocking scene
in which he straight up
lays into an unfortunate gang member
i'm vengeance what's immediately clear
from the footage
is that the batman will be unlike any
bat film that's come before it
and not just in terms of grit and
violence since writer director matt
reeves is going back to the dark
knight's early days
during the fan dome panel reeves
revealed that pattinson's bruce wayne is
in year two of his batman career
referencing the famous late 80s arc of
the same name the first trailer also
offered up a glimpse of zoe kravitz's
catwoman
and colin farrell's penguin but it's
also clear that paul deno's riddler will
be the movie's main threat
having been delayed a number of times
due to the coronavirus pandemic
the batman will now arrive in theaters
on march 4th
2022 when doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness was announced at
comic con 2019
returning director scott derrickson
claimed it would be the first
properly scary mcu film kevin feige
however was quick to downplay the idea
then during an appearance at the new
york film academy marvel's president
said that he wouldn't necessarily call
it a horror in the traditional sense
derekson exited the project over
creative differences a few weeks later
marvel wasted no time in finding a
replacement and their apparent choice
has gone down pretty well with fans
veteran horror director sam raimi began
talking to the studio about the project
in february 2020
and was soon brought on to the project
properly derekson for his part
called raymie's hiring a great choice on
marvel's part
raymie whose spider-man movies laid the
foundation for the modern superhero film
remains a fan favorite director in the
comic book world and will likely bring
some prestige to benedict cumberbatch's
second solo outing as steven strange
they'll be working from a script by
michael waldron the head writer of
upcoming disney plus series loki
a couple of new mcu characters will make
their debuts in the movie with some
sources suggesting that the story will
introduce the iconic marvel characters
clea and brother voodoo but you can
expect plenty of familiar faces to
appear too
elizabeth olsen scarlet witch is going
to feature prominently in the movie
while chuatel
edge of four benedick wong and rachel
mcadams are also expected to return
the madness begins on march 25th 2022
news that chris hemsworth and taiko
waititi were teaming up for another thor
movie broke days before comic con 2019
but the biggest announcement came at the
event itself that
natalie portman is returning to the
franchise the oscar winner portrayed
thor's earthbound love interest jane
foster in 2011's thor
in 2013's thor the dark world but was
absent for 2017's thor ragnarok with an
explanation
briefly given that the pair had broken
up she didn't dump me you know
i dumped her mutual dumping after that
portman appeared to be done with marvel
but her character in the marvel comics
has developed significantly since her
last film appearance
most notably in a 2014 story foster was
deemed worthy to wield thor's hammer
and adopted the title goddess of thunder
we don't know how this will all play out
on screen
but why tt clearly has big plans for
both portman and jane foster
aside from that the director has been
tight-lipped on plot details
but he at least dropped a few
tantalizing teases during an april 2020
watch party for thor ragnarok why tt
revealed that he intends to introduce
star sharks to the mcu for example
and also left the door open for a
possible low-key return
surprise it's also been confirmed that
the movie's main villain
gore the god butcher will be played by
mcu debutant christian bale
meanwhile tessa thompson will be back in
action as valkyrie
and the guardians of the galaxy are also
set to make an appearance
perhaps strangest of all however is the
news that the asgardian actors from
ragnarok are also returning for the
movie
this time around luke hemsworth matt
damon and sam neal
are joined by melissa mccarthy who is
playing the stage version of hella
want to know what that's all about find
out when love and thunder is released on
may 6
2022 the planned sequel to the smash hit
black panther suffered a massive blow in
august 2020 with the heartbreaking and
untimely loss of chadwick boseman
the actor was diagnosed with colon
cancer in 2016
the year he made the first of his four
appearances as the african superhero
for a number of reasons boseman chose to
keep his diagnosis private
even from marvel and filmmaker ryan
coogler kugler later said
i spent the last year preparing
imagining and writing words for him to
say
that we weren't destined to see it
leaves me broken knowing that i won't be
able to watch another close-up of him in
the monitor again
or walk up to him and ask for another
take bozeman's death was reportedly
devastating for everyone at disney but
conversations about where the franchise
should go have now begun behind the
scenes
marvel has made it clear they have no
intention of recasting the role so that
means the black panther mantle is likely
to be handed over to a new character
earlier than expected
something there's actually a well-known
president for in the comics
t'challa's younger half-sister shuri has
her black panther training fast-tracked
after he is severely injured by villains
loyal to namor
who as it happens has been rumored to
appear as the sequel's big bad
but whether is shuri another of
t'challa's allies or a brand new
character altogether
whoever takes on the mantle of black
panther will have some very big shoes to
fill
we'll see how they do on july 8th 2022
dwayne johnson has been touting a black
atom movie for well over a decade
he became officially attached to play
the character in 2014
and was originally supposed to debut as
adam and shazam
but in 2017 execs decided the character
was too big for a supporting role and
needed his own solo movie instead
news has been painfully slow since then
but things picked up a little during
dc's fan dome event in summer 2020
there wasn't any actual footage to show
but johnson nevertheless debuted a brief
teaser made up of stills created by dc's
jim lee
and instagram artist boss logic johnson
narrates the teaser in character
explaining that he was imprisoned some
5000 years earlier when his home
the fictional nation of kondok was a
melting pot of magic and powers
in the comics adam is a vengeful slave
who's granted the gifts of the wizard
shazam
and uses them for good before eventually
being led astray
johnson confirmed that the justice
society of america will feature in the
film
and we now know who's playing them all
this hodge is hawkman
noah centenaio is adam smasher quintessa
swindell is cyclone
and rounding out the main cast with his
superhero movie debut
pierce bronson is dr fate rising star
bodhi sabangi will also reportedly be
showing up as a
key yet secret character drama coet
sarah who directed johnson in disney's
jungle cruise
is working from a script by adam
steekeel who wrote the former wrestler's
2018 action or rampage
filming on black adam began in april
2021
with the movie itself set for a july 29
2022 release date
the sequel to 2018 spider-man into the
spider-verse was already in the works by
the time the original movie hit theaters
given how long the first movie took to
complete however that's not at all
surprising
into the spiderverse was four years in
the making which made fans all the more
worried about potential delays to the
project when the coronavirus pandemic
struck
thankfully the movie schedule doesn't
seem to have been affected
and lead animator nick condo confirmed
that production had officially begun
in a june 2020 tweet the second of the
original movie's post-credits scenes
gave fans a major clue about where the
story could be headed
introducing viewers to miguel o'hara aka
spider-man 2099
this future version of spidey voiced by
oscar isaac
is given a watch that allows him to
travel between dimensions
this could literally not get any weirder
reportedly
the sequel is also set to feature
japanese spider-man
while spider-man the animated series
star christopher daniel barnes has
revealed that he would love to play his
version of spider-man in the movie
he told recording time media if i could
do that again
i'd be honored into the spider verse 2
is due for release on october 7
2022 ezra miller's long-awaited solo
outing as barry allen was thrown into
peril in 2020
when a clip of him appearing to choke a
female fan went viral
nonetheless warner brothers decided to
stick by the actor
and right now the flash remains very
much in the pipeline
the project was actually given the name
flash point back in 2017 which is also
the name of an epic dc
event one which saw the flash turn the
whole universe on its head
by traveling backwards in time to save
his mother we don't know how closely
director andy muschietti and writer
christina hodson's film
will follow the well-known and beloved
art but we do at least know who's going
to be in it
barry allen's mom will be played by
maribel verdu
while ron livingston will portray his
dad having taken over the role from a
double-booked billy crudup
according to variety sir shaw monica
jackson and youtube star rudy mancuso
will
also feature in bigger news it's been
confirmed that sasha caye
has been cast as supergirl and will be
making her debut alongside the scarlet
speedster
plus ben affleck will be returning as
batman with muschietti telling vanity
fair
that affleck is a very substantial part
of the emotional impact of the movie
muskietti has also said that michael
keaton's 1989 batman would appear in the
film
playing a substantial part in barry
allen's tale however in march 2021
keaton himself told deadline that he was
unsure whether or not he would take up
the cal again
as he explained i am needing a minute to
think about it because i'm so fortunate
and blessed
i got so much going on now i'm really
into work right now
with keaton or without him the flash is
scheduled for release on november 4th
2022. kevin feige gave away nothing
about captain marvel 2 when he revealed
his mcu phase 4 plans back in 2019
but we know now a whole lot more about
the upcoming sequel
brie larson will reprise the role of
carol danvers and she will be facing off
against velvet buzzsaw
actor zoe ashton who according to
deadline
has been cast as a thus far unidentified
villain
the same outlet has revealed that tiana
paris's monica rambo
will feature reprising her one division
role as will iman valani's kamala khan
focus of the upcoming disney plus series
miss marvel
the coronavirus pandemic inevitably
slowed the movie down a little but
production on captain marvel 2
reportedly began in earnest in
early january 2021 that same month
larson spoke to lily singh about the
hiring of director nia decosta
who is set to become the first black
woman to direct an mcu movie
she said it's amazing and i'm so excited
that it's announced and i can talk about
it
nia is amazing and she got the job
because she is the best person for the
job
she just gave an incredible presentation
and i'm inspired by her
captain marvel 2 will be released on
november 11th 2022
a sequel to 2018's aquaman seemed
inevitable from the moment james wan
underwater epic dethrone the dark knight
rises as the highest grossing dc movie
ever
in january 2019 deadline revealed that
warner brothers wanted juan to oversee
development of aquaman 2
and had given the director permission to
select his own writer
a few weeks later the hollywood reporter
confirmed that david leslie johnson
mcgoldrick who co-wrote the original
movie
has been hired for the sequel and while
aquaman 2 will be very much their
brainchild
it seems that jason momoa has been
chipping in with some ideas too
in october 2019 he told entertainment
tonight
i went into warner brothers in dc and
said you know i have some ideas
they love them and james one and
everyone is like we're all taking it in
we're excited to do another one the
actor wouldn't get into specifics
but he promised that aquaman 2 was going
to be way
bigger than the first installment saying
there's a lot more in store on so many
more levels
there's going to be a lot all we know
for sure about the plot of the sequel is
that the titular hero will face off
against classic nemesis black manta
who was rescued by an obsessive
scientist in the first movie's
mid-credits scene
aquaman 2 hits theaters on december 16
2022.
released in 2019 shazam was a major win
for warner brothers with the vast
majority of critics praising the film's
departure from the somber tone that had
come to define dc movies there's nothing
official on the upcoming sequel in terms
of plot yet but we do know that director
david f sandberg and screenwriter henry
gayden are both back
and all the principal cast members are
expected to return too
but who will the shazamalee be up
against this timeout
well one of the shazam post-credit tags
introduced a talking caterpillar-like
creature
that fans of the comics will surely have
recognized as mr mine a traditional
adversary of billy batson we're going to
have together
the seven realms are about to be
ours it's also been confirmed that helen
mirren and lucy liu will play villains
by the name of hespera
and calypso respectively they're both
sisters original characters
and daughters of the god atlas whose
most popular run in the comics came
under jack kirby stewardship in the mid
70s
shazam fury of the gods will be released
on june 2nd
2023 check out one of our newest videos
right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite movies and tv shows are coming
soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one